mme yolande débat sur france 24 nous
serons toujours solidaire de l'ukraine a
lancé à joe biden lors de son discours à
la tribune des nations unies à new york
vladimir poutine veut anéantir le droit
de l'ukraine à exister a ajouté le
président américain qui a condamné
fermement le président russe après son
annonce d'une mobilisation de 300000
réservistes le président russe avait
aussi confirmé l'organisation des
référendums dans les territoires occupés
des régions de louhansk d'honnêtes
personnes ou encore à pau ridja poutine
utilisera tous les moyens nécessaires
pour protéger la russie avait il dit
volodymyr hélas qui a affirmé quant à
lui ne pas croire à l'utilisation
d'armes nucléaires par moscou sur le
terrain en tout cas les ukrainiens
continuent de combattre y compris dans
ces régions la contre offensive se
poursuit alors assistons à une escalade
jusqu'où peut-on parler de menaces
nucléaires dans des bas avec mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés à
laure mandeville bonsoir grands soirs
terre au figaro auteur de les révoltés
d'occident et ses poses édition de
l'observatoire bienvenue lors en face de
vous le général jean paul palomeros
bonsoir à vous merci de revenir dans le
débat ancien chef de l'état major de
l'armée de l'air ancien commandant
suprême allié de la transformation de
l'otan j'espère je me suis pas trompé
dans le titre de tout merci général
d'être avec nous jean de gliniasty est
avec nous bonsoir directeur de recherche
de l'iris ancien ambassadeur de france
en russie hauteur de la russie un nouvel
échiquier c'est aux éditions eyrolles
nous allons avoir avec tout au long de
l'émission elena volochine qui est notre
envoyé spécial à kiev en ukraine
également notre ancienne correspondante
en russie qu'on connaît bien justement
pour le décryptage de la propagande
russe bonsoir lna
on va tout de suite écouter sans
stéphanie on va tout de suite écouter
joe biden c'était il ya quelques
instants à new york à la tribune des
nations unies
le soir cette guerre a pour but d
atteindre le droit de l'ukraine exister
en tant qu'etat tout simplement
les 3 des ukrainiens d'exister en tant
que le peuple
où que vous soyez que vous viviez quel
que soit vos croyances
cela doit glace et votre sens que bouali
one quand
ils sont aussi de new york justement on
retrouve par skype joignent secondes six
porte parole francophone du département
d'état américain bonsoir à vous merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous
nous serons toujours solidaire de
l'ukraine c'est une condamnation ferme
de la part de joe biden un discours
d'ailleurs dû ont vis-à-vis de vladimir
poutine lui même est ce qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans une escalade entre
bayonne et poutine en ukraine
même
jusque au début de ce conflit
à vos doigts
c'est un payement des limitations celui
et
l'invasion illégale plus
c'est une contravention de la chante de
lorsqu'on reste pour être très clair
avec vous pardonnez-moi mais poutine dit
qu'il va utiliser qu'il utilisera tous
les moyens nécessaires pour protéger la
russie byden a parlé d'ailleurs de
menaces irresponsable que ferait les
états unis si la russie utilisé l'armé
nucléaire est ce que vous pouvez me le
dire ce soir
début saison pas encore des bons sens
parce que
la russie et ce matin c'est le clame
pièce qui est sous attaque personne de
m'attaque au territoire russe et d'un
comme menace
d'utilisation de
youtube ne sont pas constructives pour
pas pour tuer enfin à négocier du promat
hic
cette guerre
elles ne sont pas mais ce qu elles sont
réalistes tout de même ces menaces de
poutine d'utiliser l'armé nucléaire
volodymyr zola ce qui a l'air de
minimiser cette menace qu'est ce que
vous en dites
je crois que
c'est que ce n'est pas la russie qui est
certain c'est que si on vend ses gains
et
les ignore pas question de la défense
qu'amiens qui exercent leur droit de ses
dépenses et c'est la communauté
autour de ce principe
était évidemment l'ambassadrice
américaine a d'ailleurs évoqué un signe
de faiblesse de la part de vladimir
poutine sur twitter est ce qu'à votre
avis poutine est affaibli
je crois que the big
o
ils sont en train de réaliser que russie
a défendu ces invasions ces actions
illégales
illégitime a dû au veto du conseil de
sécurité et aussi par
c'est que
limité
[Musique]
alors est ce que justement en étant
affaibli est ce que il serait d'autant
plus dangereux johann schmidt 6 d'avenir
poutine comme peut le dire par exemple
roger cohen dans une tribune sur new
york times
notre réaction à l'invasion russe ne
peut pas être abandonnée dès facile de
l'organisation et en fait on voit
maintenant
sur le côté ukrainien
ceux qui vous soutiennent
ces 40 mans
est
directement aider l'ukraine à son
autodéfense et c'est comme ça qu'il faut
continuer
l'ukraine est en train de se décanter et
c'est
donc le principe de base aussi c'est que
les états unis vont continuer à aider
armes et l'ukraine
[Musique]
merci beaucoup je me demande si c'est
d'avoir été avec nous en direct de new
york porte parole francophone du
département d'état américain une petite
un petit tour de table justement en
réaction laure mandeville donc bon il ya
un soutien très ferme de joe biden on
l'a vu à la tribune on répétait donc par
le par le porte-parole même s'il a été
prudent justement sur vladimir poutine
en tant que tel sur cette menace
nucléaire ou pas à ce cours est ce qu'on
est dans une escalade quand même pour ce
qui est clair c'est que j'admire poutine
et s'entend en fait que le sol se dérobe
sous ses pieds
en ukraine où il est en train de de
subir une défaite extrêmement importante
et avec l'aide qu'apporte aujourd'hui
l'occident à l'ukraine
cent ans cela essai de contre attaquer
et je dirais se lance dans une fuite en
avant parce qu'il sait très bien en fait
que avec cette guerre il a toutes
engagées il ne peut plus reculer et donc
il avance et il avance sur tous les
fronts que tout ils utilisent tout ce
qu'il peut c'est une méthode qui lui
ressemble beaucoup c'est à dire que
cette guerre est menée sur à la fois sur
le front militaire il mobilise
maintenant il annonce la mobilisation
partielle de la population ce qui est
une mesure absolument énorme sur le plan
politique qui va peut-être d'ailleurs
lui être fatale ou en tout cas à faiblir
terriblement son pouvoir et il se lance
dans un chantage vis-à-vis de l'occident
puisqu'il voit qu'il perd du terrain il
dit si vous remettez en cause en fait le
terrain que j'ai avalé je vous balance
des armes nucléaires dans la figure et
donc c'est une c'est un chantage au plus
haut niveau et son calcul c'est
évidemment pour que nous allons avoir
peur que nous allons céder que notre
soutien puisque pour lui ils mesurent en
permanence le soutien occidental l'état
des populations l'état des classes
politiques la france l'allemagne
l'europe tout ça est donc il est sur un
et sur plusieurs échiquiers et il il
allume toutes les touts les contre-feux
qu'il peut allumer pour essayer d'acide
d'échapper à la défaite vers la
catastrophe vers lequel il est en train
d'amener son emmené son pays qui est
irrémédiable ce que vous avez à dire oui
je pense qu'à terme ce sera une
véritable catastrophe pour la russie je
vais vous faire réagir mais avant on va
faire un petit pont en images justement
sur ce discours de vladimir poutine qui
avait lieu ce matin dans lequel il a
annoncé qu'il allait mobiliser enfin une
mobilisation partielle dit-il de
justement des russes
face à la contre-offensive ukrainienne
vladimir poutine choisi l'escaladent je
suis dans une adresse retransmises à la
télévision russe mercredi le chef du
kremlin dénoncent selon ses mots un
chantage nucléaire de l'occident et
menace
est une impasse je tiens à vous rappeler
que notre pays dispose également de
diverses armes de destruction et à
certains égards elles sont même plus
moderne que celle des pays de l'otan
s'il ya une menace pour l'intégrité
territoriale de notre pays afin de
protéger la russie et notre peuple nous
utiliseront certainement tous les moyens
à notre disposition ce n'est pas du
bluff depuis presque un mois l'armée
ukrainienne a lancé une vaste
contre-offensive et repris des dizaines
de localités à l'armée russe ce mercredi
vladimir poutine autorise aussi une
mobilisation partielle c'est à dire
l'envoi d'environ 300 milles réservistes
vers le front ukrainien pour le ministre
britannique de la défense ben wallace
cette mobilisation est un aveu d'échec
et montre que l'ukraine est en train de
gagner pour l'union européenne c'est le
signe du désarroi de vladimir poutine
pour le chancelier allemand elle montre
que l' attaque russe en ukraine n'est
pas couronnée de succès enfin vladimir
poutine a également confirmé la tenue de
référendum d'annexion dans les
républiques séparatistes de john yates
louhansk et les régions occupées 2
apories jefferson
général jean paul palomeros est un aveu
de faiblesse ces trois cent mille
réservistes mobilisés par poutine ou pas
est-ce qu effectivement c'est une fuite
en avant comme à l'air de le dire alors
l'heure même ville je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les cartes sont
clairement sur la table on s'attendait à
une forme de mobilisation pour trois
raisons d'abord pour satisfaire quand
même c'est sont à l'extrême ce qu'on
appelle les faucons qui eux auraient
sans doute voulu qu'il aille plus loin
ensuite parce que il subit en ce moment
en tout cas une défaite dans le nord au
nord du nord massue nos résidents basse
et qu'il a besoin quelque part de
montrer que qu'il fait un effort pour
contrer cette offensive est le troisième
point qui est souligné par le ministre
de la défense général chez hugo c'est
que évidemment ils sont en train de
mesurer les russes l'étendue des
problèmes que posent l'occupation
d'affront l'a dit lui même deux mille
kilomètres mais tout est dans la
profondeur donc il ya trois objectifs et
pour moi aucun ne sera atteint pourquoi
parce que les faucons n'en n'auront pas
assez
ceux dont disent ils on voudrait plus
secundo parce que la mobilisation pour
renforcer les forces de première ligne
ça ne sera pas efficace avant bien
longtemps il faut former entraîné et
leur fournir des armes alors que les
forces de première ligne n'ont pas
d'armes aujourd'hui et troisièmement
parce que ces forces d'occupation
si vous voulez ça se construit pas non
plus comme ça il encore faudrait-il que
poutine que les forces russes tiennent
les lignes qu'elle tienne aujourd'hui
pour qu'il y ait encore occupations dans
vous voyez on est dans un imbroglio moi
je pense que tout ça n'a pas à rennes
l'effet médiatique
ça va certainement toucher les
populations
mais en termes militaires ça n'aura pas
d'effet et en tout cas pas dans le court
terme c'est à dire ça n'aura pas d'effet
ça veut dire on continue une guerre de
positions sur le terrain
avec tout de même et c'est là que c'est
important parce que les ukrainiens ils
sont évidemment tout intérêt à continuer
cette guerre de mouvement ils ont repris
l'initiative
il faut surtout pas qu'il a l'âge
d'autant plus que c'est ces référendums
qui arrivent ils doivent ils doivent se
faire sous la pression et tout ce que
les ukrainiens pourront gagner ça sera
autant que qui reprendront quelque part
apporté une gagner un mètre carré pour
les ukrainiens c'est utile c'est
important elena volochine vous qui est
la spécialiste du discours de propagande
russe même si vous êtes là en ce moment
à kiev en ukraine envoyé spécial pour
france 24 est-ce qu'il a parlé
d'ailleurs vladimir poutine de d'un
combat pas tant pas vraiment seul il a
dit que c'était un combat en fait pas
seulement contre les ukrainiens mais
contre l'occident
oui ça il le répète depuis le début de
la guerre que l'occident a déclaré une
guerre à la russie et que selon la
rhétorique russe les etats-unis seraient
prêts à combattre la russie jusqu'au
dernier en ukrainien il estime que
l'ukraine pour le washington est un
proxy pour attaquer la russie mais c'est
vous dire à quel point vladimir poutine
écrit un mythe réécrit l'histoire à
l'envers je me trouve aujourd'hui place
maïdan ici j'étais là il ya huit ans
pour couvrir ce que les ukrainiens
appelle la révolution de la dignité
lorsqu'ils se sont soulevés contre ce
régime pro russe corrompu du président
victor ianoukovitch et pour défendre
leur leurs velléités d'adhérer aux
valeurs européennes et d'intégrer
l'union européenne et bien à l'époque
déjà vladimir poutine parlé de la
nécessité d'aller défendre les
russophones du dombass contre les
génocides prétendument de nazis qui
aurait pris le pouvoir à kiev vous avez
vu ce qu'il a fait par la suite en
annexant la crimée en provoquant la
guerre dans le donbass en alimentant ce
conflit par de l'argent par des troupes
par des armes aujourd'hui c'est la ddt
deuxième fois depuis la grande invasion
du 24 février qu'il parle de menace
nucléaire pour encore une fois défendre
soi disant l'intégrité territoriale de
la russie donc on est toujours dans ce
mythe qui inverse celui qui défend et
celui qui attaque l'agresseur et
l'agressé donc on voit à quel point où
mène finalement cette rhétorique puisque
vous en parlais à l'instant il va y
avoir des référendums dans ces
territoires non seulement à donner à ce
cas lourds ans qui ont été de facto si
l'on peut dire annexé par la russie bien
qu'elle ne les ait reconnu que récemment
mais pas sportive et administrativement
mis sous sa tutelle depuis huit ans déjà
à ces deux territoires de donetsk et de
laurent scalese de l'ukraine désormais
avec les territoires nouvellement
occupez-vous les citiez carson
zaporizhya une partie de la région de
zaporijia une partie de la région de
kharkiv que les ukrainiens sont en train
de reprendre mais en tout cas à carson
mais litho paul ou encore donc dans ses
régions eh bien il va y avoir des
référendums les autorités locales
pro-russes collaborationniste l'ont
annoncé et à partir de ce moment là on a
déjà entendu des voix en russie d'hier
mais à partir du moment où ces
territoires devienne la russie et bien
cela servira le discours de vladimir
poutine à dire que c'est encore plus que
c'est finalement le territoire de la
russie qui est attaqué c'est pour ça que
le conseiller du président ukrainien
aujourd'hui mirel peu de l'âme disait
mais quelle absurdité d'abord ils nous
attaquent et ensuite il nous parce qu'on
veut reprendre nos territoires il nous
accuse d'attaqué voilà cette réalité
parallèle dans laquelle sont plongés les
ukrainiens et 10 sont parfaitement
habitué mais c'est vous dire si ce genre
de propos ce genre de menaces est
ensuite mise à exécution par vladimir
poutine c'est pour cela que on a envie
de dire qu'il bluffe que les ukrainiens
sans doute au fond parce que l'être
humain s'habitue à tout n'ont pas envie
de croire à cette attaque nucléaire mais
vous le dit mme irène ski le président
ukrainien la 10 personnes nées dans sa
tête puisqu'il considère que vladimir
poutine est un fou il l'a 10 personnes
et dans sa tête et donc personne ne peut
exclure quoi que ce soit venant du
président russe ni donc cette menace
nucléaire jean de gliniasty cette
organisation des référendum donc dans
quatre régions d'ukraine qui ne sont pas
d'ailleurs toutes occupées alpha ne sont
pas 100 % occupée par les russes n ya
toujours des combats est ce que c'est
une forme de c'est un peu ce que disait
elena aussi est-ce que c'est aussi une
façon de tracer une sorte de nous ligne
rouge et donc de faire en sorte que
l'escaladé en fait la soie et franchit
une nouvelle étape c'est une
sanctuarisation en tout cas une
tentative de son actualisation moi j'ai
été très frappé par
l'extrême prudence du président byden en
ce qui concerne la menace nucléaire
russe alors choisi son porte-parole non
plus hélène ce qui l'a écarté d'un
revers de main mais je crois que les
américains les prennent très au sérieux
il faut se rappeler que obama peu avant
de partir a fait une sorte de testament
de politique étrangère où la france
n'était pas très gâté d'ailleurs et où
il avait dit il faut faire attention en
ukraine parce qu'en cas d' escalade
parce que c'est très émotionnel pour la
russie la russie aura toujours un cran
d'avancé sur nous et je pense que byden
qui était à l'époque vice-président doit
avoir en tête ce qu'a dit obama à
l'époque ce que pensait obama à l'époque
et je trouvais il n'y a pas d'escaladé à
une escalade du côté russe mais il ya
pas d escalade du côté mais les
américains ils ont dit nous on continue
à soutenir l'ukraine jusqu'au bout et en
cas de menace nucléaire il n'y aurait
pas ce qu il a dit non non non en fait
c'est plutôt ça veut dire
qu'effectivement ils envisagent cette
possibilité
sans dire exactement ce qu'il ferait
laure mandeville intéressant tout de
même de voir qu'il ya des manifestations
en russie avec 200 arrestations que les
prix d'après ce qu'on a vu dans un
différents sites d'information
les prix des billets donc entre moscou
et istanbul sur turkish airlines par
exemple ont explosé littéralement que
les vols sont pleins donc il ya un
certain nombre de russes qui veulent
échapper à cette mobilisation exactement
et je crois que c'est pour ça qu'on est
rentrée elle a aussi vu on et se
superposent des fronts disent très
différents et c'est là on est dans la
politique et sur le front de cette
société russe qui jusqu'à présent n'a
pas vraiment bougé enfin il ya eu des
manifestations mais qui ont été
réprimées avec une violence qui a fait
qu'elles se sont quand même arrêté assez
vite et depuis il y avait on subissait
et quand quelques rébellion quand même
rêver les gens nous aurons l'organe par
exemple effectivement alla pougatcheva
est ce que je trouve personnellement
extrêmement intéressant parce que c'est
une femme qui bénéficie dans ce qu'on
appelle le peuple je dirais aux néo
soviétique c'est à dire l'électorat
finalement de la nostalgie qui est qui a
sans doute voté pour l'admirent poutine
qu'ils qui est très qui adore cette
femme est donc le fait qu'elle se
manifeste de manière quand même très
claire contre la guerre et qu'elle
demande à être à devenir un agent de
l'étranger pour eur par solidarité avec
son époux qui est un acteur célèbre qui
a été décrétée agents de l'étranger
c'est une manière en fait de porter ça
comme une médaille et donc de de défier
le pouvoir donc ça c'est vraiment
intéressant et je dirais que mes mais si
vous voulez faut pas oublier que par
exemple le sushi ma en 1904 quand
l'alarmé russe est parti se battre dans
cette guerre complètement folle au japon
vous savez dans la mer du japon elle a
envoyé la troupe est donc d'aider des
jeunes et moins jeunes
russe de la campagne etc et il ya eu ça
s'est très mal terminée il ya eu des
rébellions il ya eu ils ont perdu dans
une défaite écrasante et ça a été le
début de la révolution c'est le début de
la révolution est donc vous vous pensez
peut-être un changement de régime à
l'ispa encore bas encore mais c'est vrai
que il ya et on est on est serein sur
quelque chose d'extrêmement mouvement de
mouvement qui peut changer très
rapidement il ya eu des rumeurs comme
quoi par exemple les généraux quand que
qu'il y aurait eu une réunion du conseil
de sécurité juste avant ce discours est
que poutine aurait demande aurait parlé
cette mobilisation et une partie des
généraux auraient dit qu'ils étaient
montre c'est des rumeurs insistantes qui
a notamment à kiev et donc je ne sais
pas du tout ce qu'il en est mais c'est
vrai que l'histoire de la menace
nucléaire moi je serais d'accord à la
fois avec ce que ce que disait lna il me
semble qu'il faut prendre au sérieux le
discours de poutine parce qu'au fond il
fait pratiquer il fait très souvent ce
qu'il dit il ya un autre élément
inquiétant c je dirais une sorte de
fascisation des esprits dans son
entourage c'est à dire une espèce de
haine qui est tellement eu si vous
voulez à couper au couteau qui
s'expriment publiquement contre
l'occident contre les ukrainiens contre
l'occident et donc on sent une envie
d'en découdre je dirais violente et
viscérale mais il y a aussi le calcul et
en même temps là la volonté de faire
peur ça c'est le côté je dirais presque
mafieux de poutine vous savez d'hommes
qui a grandi dans la rue et qui met tout
son côté pour faire trembler
l'adversaire est finalement qu il se
rende général de savoir ce qu'ils
nomment héros justement que c'est
possible ou pas ce que vous pouvez
rebondir sur ce qu'a dit justement laure
mandeville est ce qu on est d'abord
est-ce qu'il ya effectivement une sorte
de débandade côté russe avec cette
population qui est en tout cas une
partie qui essayent de fuir pour pas
être mobilisés on a parlé déjà de cette
armée russe qui a été défaite dans un
certain nombre de villes dont cannes
centre d'affaiblissement militaire côté
russe et est ce que d'un autre côté il y
a effectivement cette cette propagande
qui fait que vous avez c'est dur autour
de lui à qui pousserait au contraire
aller beaucoup plus loin
g bassila une débandade enfin avant tout
le monde tous les russes ont pas les
moyens de payer dix mille euros et un
billet d'avion là on parle de quelques
populations m on voit bien où sont
d'ailleurs recruté les réservistes pour
l'instant ils sont pas recruter ni dans
les milieux étudiants ils sont recrutés
le taux dans les provinces où tim essaye
de ménager une grande métropole donc est
ce qu'ils continuent à essayer de les
ménager lorsqu'il dit qu'il va faire une
mobilisation partielle est ce qu'on
passe pas un autre france sur la guerre
si j'ai bien compris la dynamique de la
mobilisation partielle c'est exactement
ce à quoi continuer il va aller chercher
en fait des gens qui ont fait leur
service et ces gens là c'est plutôt des
gens un peu plus âgés doivent pas être
ravi de retourner dans un combat qui les
concerne pas et sur lequel ils doivent
prendre ils vont prendre tous les
risques mais je crois surtout si on
regarde l'équation militaire
il faut il faut quand même faire
attention de ne pas tomber dans l'excès
parce que les russes si la guerre
s'arrêter aujourd'hui les russes
auraient gagné mais si elle s'arrêtait
la suède sont ils ont pris effectivement
une part non négligeable du alors est ce
que les ukrainiens sont capables d'aller
beaucoup plus loin ils ont fait
magnifique percée il faut le remarquer
mais ils n'ont pas encore pris quand
même débile critiquons mais il joue ma
part il ils ont un très très gros
travail à faire je suis pas certain
moussa dans le sud essentiellement
ils ont horizons aussi plusieurs
directions l'héroïne leur en imposer et
et je suis pas certain que l'armée
ukrainienne en état et avec tout le
soutien occidental soit capable de
porter le fer sur l'ensemble sur ces
1000 kilomètres de front donc c c'est un
combat qui va être difficile l'hiver va
arriver aussi on sait jamais pour mac et
il sera le plus favorable donc
l'ours russe et est blessé il est pas
mort et quand il est blessé les plus il
est plus dangereux
ça évidemment poutine ne va pas
réconforter ses capacités instantanément
dans qui bat il va monter les
bombardements il faut aussi attendre sur
les sources d'énergie il va rendre
l'hiver russe beaucoup plus difficile il
va rendre l'univers ukrainien beaucoup
plus difficile en tout cas en russie ans
on disait la population beaucoup moins
peur qu'avant on va regarder quelques
réactions qui sur place de manifestants
avant on avait peur mais maintenant le
pire est derrière nous je suis contre la
guerre et je suis contre la mobilisation
des réservistes
cette manifestation était utile non mais
il faut faire quelque chose
il n'y a pas de peur
il ya de la haine envers le régime en
place et maintenant elles vont prendre
la vie de nos enfants
j'ai un fils de 18 ans
elena et elena volochine là il ya de la
haine contre le régime en place on
entend 7,7 moscovite dire ça ils vont
prendre nos enfants il commence
véritablement à se manifester c'est
russe
ça pourra avoir un impact
il y aura fait de la répression
c'est vous savez
c'est très difficile c'est très
douloureux comme thème parce que
effectivement il ya eu cette vague de
répression après après le début de
l'invasion le 24 février avec ses lois
extrêmement dure adoptée contre toute
expression qui condamnerait la guerre en
ukraine qui avec l'interdît d'abord de
l'appeler guerre qui ensuite interdit
même de prononcer le mot paix ou de
sortir dans la rue avec une feuille
blanche on a vu des arrestations qui
était juste finalement dès protestation
silencieuse est juste le signe de
protester et est réprimé donc il ya eu
cette espèce de black out de mise sous
chape de plomb de tout de toute
expression en russie on voit aujourd'hui
cette explosion d'autant plus
impressionnante d'une population devenue
par la peur encore plus grande qu'avant
passive
observer tout ceci ceux qui n'ont pas pu
partir bien sûr ceux qui sont restés en
russie observé tout ceci avec horreur et
consternation et aujourd'hui ce sont ces
dans un dernier élan de désespoir que
ces gens là ils sortent dans la rue
parce que la mobilisation il faut voir
que cela réveille beaucoup beaucoup chez
les russes dans l'imaginaire collectif
qui est dans un état de guerre de
douleurs de deuil finalement quelque
part permanent entre les conflits
d'afghanistan de tchétchénie même la
mémoire de la seconde guerre aujourd'hui
la mobilisation c'est pour ça aussi que
vladimir poutine ne déclarent pas de
mobilisation totale en russie parce que
comprendre que nous entrons que nous
devons être dans un effort de guerre ça
quelque chose c'est quelque chose de
très douloureux pour les russes même
pour ceux qui se disent pour l'opération
spéciale alors bien même qu'ils se
disent aussi pour la paix mais pour eux
dans le discours us l'opération spéciale
c'est quelque chose qui est là pour
garantir la paix dans le mythe russe
donc il faut vraiment comprendre tout ce
mécanisme complexe qui peine à ce
soulèvement aujourd'hui très
certainement la répression sera très
forte de plus en plus fortes on a vu
hier même encore ces lois a donc adopté
envers ceux qui combattent parce qu'on
sait qu'il ya beaucoup de velléités de
désertion que l'armée russe et ceux qui
combattent sont complètement découragés
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'ils ont
fuies de ce que disent les soldats
ukrainien qui mène la contre offensive
leurs positions à l'est au nord-est et
bien aujourd'hui il faut il faut envoyer
des gens au front c'est ce que dit
vladimir poutine est donc cette
mobilisation elle passe très très mal et
il y a encore une nouvelle vague de
départs il faut savoir que tout début du
conflit il ya des milliers de russes qui
sont partis dont bruce qui sont partis
craignant justement la mobilisation
certains sont revenus parce qu'on le
disait les gens s'habituent à tous ils
ont envie de rentrer chez eux et
finalement quelque part ils n'y croient
plus et donc là maintenant et bien le
couperet est tombé ça se refermer ils
sentent de nouveau ce set ce rideau de
fer quelque part qui s'abat sur la
russie est donc effectivement il ya un
mouvement d'horreur et de consternation
d'autant plus que si on le comprend bien
et les juristes en sont encore à
interpréter mais qu'est ce que cela va
vouloir dire exactement pour les russes
toutes ces mesures ce n'est pas clair
mais il y a aujourd'hui vraiment cette
peur que les frontières se ferment cette
peur des parents pour leurs enfants qui
vont être envoyés au front qui pousse
malgré la répression malgré ces mesures
drastiques qui punissent de plusieurs
années d'emprisonnement
désormais les déserteurs et même ceux
qui se rendent prisonniers et bien tout
ceci pousse néanmoins les russes à
sortir manifester dans la rue jean de
gliniasty oui c'est ce que disait cette
femme où cet homme se ruent s'il disait
non ça ne sert à rien mais runje quand
même en fait c'est
évidemment ils sont habitués
la répression est donc moi je ne dirais
pas ça sert à rien ce sont des messages
qui passe au pouvoir ont parlé de la
liberté de circuler il ya un point
qu'elle est très importants la
principale liberté qui a été acquise par
les russes après la chute de l'urss
c'est la liberté de sortir c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que cette idée de supprimer
les visas pour les russes tellement
contre-productive tellement idiote mais
la liberté et c'est bien oui si on était
à contre à contre emploi du temps de
l'union soviétique l'union sovétique
empêcher les russes de sortir et nous on
essayait de les attirer et maintenant
celle inverse mais pourquoi parce que
pour les russes la première des libertés
c'est celle de voyages à l'extérieur et
le jour où poutine bloquent le départ
des russes c'est la fin d'une époque et
ça signifie quelque part à un moment sa
mort politique parce que ça c'est une
liberté fondamentale c'est celle à
laquelle les russes ne renonce ne
renoncerons pas mais vous pensez comme
l'hormone ville qu'effectivement il
pourrait y avoir un changement de régime
à l'issue de ce concert de divas percolé
c'est pas immédiat ce genre de choses de
façon changement de régime ne peut
apparaître cas parce que le ne partir
que du cercle restreint puisque tout est
verrouillé et que le président contrôle
des services de sécurité la tête de la
bêta et donc le temps que ça remonte de
la base jusqu'au cercle restreint il
faut du temps je pense ça sera pas du
jour au lendemain ou bien alors à ce
moment là ce serait absolument
dramatique et par ailleurs il est très
probable que la déstabilisation
de poutine viendra de sa droite et non
pas de sa gauche à ceux qui tiennent le
pouvoir c'est ce qu'ils sont à droite et
on voit très bien que cette affaire de
référendum c'est un gage donné à son
extrême droite pushy l'ine le gouverneur
de logan sont des gens qui ne brille pas
par il suffit de les voir
se sont pas des intellectuels de gauche
et ils sont soutenus la sphère de
lougansk de donetsk et toujours eu des
répercussions très profonde intérieur de
la russie donc il donne des gages à sa
droite parce qu'il a peur d'elle à son
extrême droite nationaliste
la chine en tout cas appelé aujourd'hui
un cessez le feu à travers le dialogue
dans le conflit en ukraine on écoute le
porte-parole du ministère des affaires
étrangères chinois on me dit qu'on ne
l'a pas enfin en tout cas il l'a dit et
c'est assez intéressant lors parce que
la chine et la russie ont affiché quand
même vraiment une alliance la semaine
dernière en ouzbékistan et qu'on se dit
que les chinois ne sont pas forcément le
meilleur allié de poutine en tout cas là
il appelle à ce cessez le feu est il
qu'ils ont d'ailleurs ça on va l'écouter
parce qu'il dit aussi la nécessité de
respecter l'intégrité territoriale de
tous les pays on va l'écouter
nous maintenons que l'intégrité
souveraineté territoriale de tous les
pays doit être respectée comme la charte
des nations unies les préoccupations
légitimes de tous les pays en matière de
sécurité doivent être prises au sérieux
et tous les efforts visant à la
résolution pacifique des crises doivent
être soutenus la chine appelle les
parties concernées à résoudre
correctement leurs différends par le
dialogue et la consultation elle est
prête à travailler avec la communauté
internationale pour continuer à jouer un
rôle constructif nécessité de respecter
l'intégrité territoriale de tous les
pays intéressant ce que vient enfin moi
je veux ça toute façon c'est pas une
surprise puisque les chinois qui ont
également eu des problèmes de
séparatisme c'est sont absolument jeu
comment dire extrêmement sourcilleux sur
toutes les questions de souveraineté et
c'est vrai qu'aussi
même s'il y a une alliance sino-russe
enfin en tout cas oui une sorte
d'alliance c'est une alliance à
géométrie variable et les chinois sont
restés quand même depuis le début assez
prudent dans toute cette affaire c'est à
dire que oui il ya des contacts oui on
rachète une partie du pétrole qui
devaient être vendus à l'occident mais
les chinois par exemple je pense ne voit
pas d'un bon oeil du tout les menaces de
nucléaires qui sont proférées par
vladimir poutine car eux ils ont un
autre agenda à eux aussi ils ont un
agenda qui est un agenda disons de de
conquête du pouvoir mondial disons et de
ils veulent aller où ils veulent comment
dire soumettre les états unis en tout
cas devenir les plus grands plus grand
que les états unis ou instaurer avec une
sorte de bipolarité mais ils n'ont pas
besoin d'eux ils ne veulent pas le faire
par la guerre ils le font par l'économie
ils le font par la pression peut-être
taiwan ils ont regardé ce qui se passait
et je crois qu'il voit que les choses se
passent mal tourner mal et ils n'ont pas
du tout envie que ça dégénère général
vous êtes d'accord oui oui globalement
je suis d'accord mais pour moi c'est pas
une alliance qu'on a vu la semaine
dernière c'est des intérêts communs à un
moment donné sur certains points mais je
trouve que les mots sont forts et bien
même eu de la part des chinois une sorte
d' escalade entre guillemets pour
réaffirmer le droit des peuples à
l'inter j'invite tangibilité des
frontières donc on voit que il s'écarte
le fait même s'en souvient que monsieur
poutine et voulu répondre avant même que
la question lui soit posée aux
questions que se posaient pour le moins
les chinois sur ce qui se passait en
ukraine c'est quand même révélateur donc
je suis d'accord sur le fond sont
opportunistes en fait dans cette
alliance opportuniste si ça affaiblit ap
les américains c'est toujours ça à
prendre mais pas au point de remettre en
cause la manière dont il voit la
direction du monde futur avec un smart
power en quelque sorte et puis tout en
construisant quand même une armée digne
de ce nom pour se faire respecter on
n'espère pas plus les
pense que la chine pas beaucoup à perdre
en s'associant de trop près à poutine
aujourd'hui jean de gliniasty donc ils
mettent un peu de distance
il n'en reste pas moins que un appel au
cessez-le-feu c'est un extraordinaire
coup de coup de main donné aux russes
les et les lg d'ukrainiens veulent pas
d'un cessez-le-feu d'ailleurs un moment
notre propre président a dit fois
cessez-le-feu de l'apady longtemps parce
que le cessez-le-feu
ça veut dire qu'on s'arrête sur les
frontières actuelles et russes ne
demande que ça donc en fait la
déclaration chinoise les plus nuancé
qu'il n'y paraît au premier regard il ya
toute une subtilité dans la position
chinoise et je ne pense pas que les
russes soient forcément mécontent de ce
type de déclarer en tout cas il ne
s'agissait pas du côté des modèles
macron d'appeler à cesser le feu à cette
fin les née à new york on va on va
l'écouter justement en marge de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies à
new york emmanuel macron aujourd'hui ce
à quoi j'appelle la russie au premier
chef et tous c'est que nous mettions
tous c'est évidemment le cessez le feu
et la paix et c'est que tout le monde
puisse mettre maintenant le maximum de
pression sur le président poutine pour
qu'il cesse cette guerre qui n'a plus
aucun sens et je me félicite des
déclarations récentes du président
chinois du premier ministre indien et je
souhaite que dans la lignée de ce que
j'ai pu exprimer hier à la tribune de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
nous puissions nous unir et
progressivement être de plus en plus
nombreux pour appeler au cessez le feu
et à la paix qui est la seule voie
acceptable dans ce conflit je pense que
toute escalade même verbale ne mène à
rien donc en fait il a appelé au cessez
le feu pardonnez moi mais parce que hier
il était très ferme dans son discours
aux nations unies donc là effectivement
on a un emmanuel macron un peu différent
lors mondeville enfin les russes l'ont
déjà répondu qu'il a répondu aujourd'hui
c'est l' escalade n'y a pas de cessez le
feu ces lycées la mobilisation ils vont
mettre le paquet et je crois d'ailleurs
qu'il a sousse et dimitri medvedev ou je
sais plus qui a dit qu' il allait
être beaucoup plus dur beaucoup plus
agressif dans leurs frappes je sais plus
lequel d'entre eux a dit on va y aura on
va enlever les gants alors on a envie de
se demander qu'est ce que ça veut dire
vu la manière dont ils sont comportés
les gens ont compris qu'ils avaient pris
de gants pour l'instant non il n'avait
pas pris des gants mais
ça peut vouloir dire que ils vont ils
peuvent continuer à se déchaîner on n'a
pas le sens du mot impossible on n'a pas
le sentiment en tout cas quand ils
s'apprêtent à cesser le feu mais
justement pourquoi disent croire
emmanuel macron hier à parler de
l'impérialisme de poutine y avait un
discours très offensif aux nations unies
là effectivement aujourd'hui cessez le
feu alors il dit effectivement l'inde
s'est rallié plus tôt à la position
occidentale
en tout cas la condamner mais le conflit
en ukraine en étant quand même en
gardant cette position de l'anah minier
il prend bien garde de définir les
conditions du cessez le feu c'est ça
bien sûr tout le monde ne peut
qu'inspirer quelque part à la paix est
donc quelque part un cessez-le-feu le
tout est de savoir dans quelles
conditions il est clair que c'est
inadmissible pour les ukrainiens
aujourd'hui en état des choses sinon les
russes auraient gagné pour les russes ça
serait sans doute acceptable à voir mais
pour l'occident ça me semble tout à fait
inacceptable également près il arrivera
un moment peut-être où la question se
posera savoir jusqu'où les ukrainiens
mellacois sol les choses seront un jour
j ce cours en ce moment elle ne se pose
pas cette question non on est pas dans
l'ex qui se passera n'existe pas sur le
terrain on est quand même très très loin
d'un cessez-le-feu quelqu'un donc on est
dans l'escaladé reprendre le titre de
l'émission jean n'est qu'une escalade du
côté russe du côté occidental on
persiste on fait la même chose on est
logique
mais il n'y a pas de surenchère
by dane a dit qu'ils ne mettraient pas
un soldat ne livre pas les avions il ne
déclare pas la russie est un terroriste
non on est sur une ligne extrêmement
défini cas les cadres et donc livraisons
d'armes y compris des armes l'ont portée
oui nous avions un certain point pour
l'instant on n'a pas autorisé des armes
à très longue portée non les 100
kilomètres donc 340 quand même là pour
l'instant nous étaient les physiques
manifestement des journées dans les 100
km fixer les idées donc vraiment des
armes de terrain de combat proche
tactique on n'est pas justement dans ces
armes l'emporter que demande évidemment
la gêne ce qui est que pour l'instant
les américains ne veulent pas lui
accorder donc on continue sur le terrain
en tout cas à rester dans cette guerre
de plaisance escalade
de notre côté il a pâti là mais j'ai du
mal à penser qu'il n'ya pas quand même
une réflexion qui commence dans les
chancelleries occidentales sur comment
on fait avec un an qu'il ya un problème
russe un problème et gars problèmes
russes et qu'est ce qu'on fait avec un
régime et un homme qui d'une certaine
manière affiche ouvertement qu'il peut
annexé un territoire dire que c'est à
lui et menacé de de brandir la menace
claire si on dit que c'est plus à lui et
donc est ce que là il ya un vrai il ya
une vraie question en fait sur la
manière dont les occidentaux doivent
doivent répondre doivent se coordonner
et c est donc je pense qu'on devrait
voir dans l'esprit des ivoiriens ne
pense plus ferme le monde mais c'est la
réponse européenne actuelle avait
peut-être un peu dans la manière de
répondre de comment les occidentaux
doivent en aucun cas la rhétorique il
faut utiliser que quel type de fermeté
parce que si
si on était tenté en fait de dirhams et
il va bien falloir refaire la paix à
faire la paix il ya beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs qu'on entend en france dire
ça faisons la paix sinon on va avoir des
armes nucléaires sur la tête mais on
comprend bien que si on accepte et ça ça
serait la fin de la dissuasion nucléaire
en fait
oui alors la dissuasion nucléaire repose
sur sa crédibilité bien sûr on a des
doctrines qui sont tellement différentes
que il faut pas qu'on lise l'action des
russes et de poutine à l'aune de notre
propre doctrine nous le nucléaire c'est
l'accent actualisation maintenant il
faut toujours se poser la question à qui
le crime profite qu à quoi ça servirait
à quoi si poutine aujourd'hui vraiment
décidé d'employer des attaques des armes
nucléaires de moindre intensité de
moindre portée
à quoi ça va servir sur le théâtre j'ai
du mal à définir il ya héros risée tu
assures vraiment théorisé il faudrait
quand même après supporter toutes les
conséquences de cet acte sortir un peu
que le boîte
le diable nucléaire de sa boîte on le
fera plus rentrer qu'est ce qui peut se
passer donc tout in sais pas mais ce qui
est certain c'est que s'il est acculé à
un moment donné si vraiment tout devait
s'écrouler là je crois que la question
se poserait vraiment tant qu'il y assez
feront que la russie reste à peu près
sur ces lignes il n'ya pas d'écoulement
du château de carte en quelque sorte je
pense que c'est tout à fait rhétorique
depuis le début on entend la même le
même discours c'est pas pour ça qu'il
faut pas le prendre au sérieux bien
entendu dire on a toujours pris au
sérieux pendant la guerre froide on le
prenait très au sérieux en prenait très
au sérieux les armements soviétique on a
réussit même à créer des accords pour
diminuer le risque c'est un peu le
problème aujourd'hui c'est tous ces
accords ils ont volé en fumée mais ça va
être extrêmement difficile de renouer un
dialogue pour essayer de refroidir la
marmite en quelque sorte la marmite dont
canepa est loin d'être refroidie elle
est loin d'être refroidit le vrai danger
c'est que la question craignaient les
totalement émotionnel et irrationnel
pour une grande partie de
l'establishment russe voilà et c'est
pour ça que cette menace nucléaire doit
être
je dis pas prise au sérieux mais en tout
cas considérés avec
avec sérieux parce que
il y un risque
poutine est dans la négation totale de
l'état de l'état ukrainien il considère
que ben que c'est la russie quoi veut et
donc il est légitime qu'il légitime à le
sanctuary zay et qu il le défendra
jusqu'au bout la moitié de la population
risque ne partage pas ce point de vue
mais ceux qui le partage sont au pouvoir
et il organise se réfère un homme en
plus sur ces territoires ces régions et
craignent à n'occuper merci beaucoup
général jean paul palomeros d'avoir été
avec nous merci laure mandeville merci à
vous jean de gliniasty merci à elena à
vau-l'eau chine qui était avec nous donc
pendant l'émission et merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivis reste avec nous sur
france 24